and ben is really nervous because he is  afraid of cops i'm not afraid of cops i  have no reason to be i never break any  laws ever  because i'm deathly afraid of cops  look nope  i've always liked you but the new ports  run this town and frankly they've  donated a lot of money to the department  mo money no problems that's what i  always say  how about mo money more protected kevlar  vest that save lives i i sometimes i say  that too i understand you need to think  about it but if you were gonna make a  decision guys are throwing me a little  retirement thing tonight at  o'flynnigan's  there's gonna be beer so i want you to  swing by i'll give you an answer  weirdo can come too all right  let's go oh hey uh may i say the boys in  blue stop our heroes obviously some more  than others  oh boy here comes  9 11. and we're walking okay